the media are over the moon about a new
poll from Pew Research Center the new
poll surveyed some 40,000 people across
37 countries and it turns out foreigners
don't like President Trump as much as
they liked President Obama
shocker while 64% of such foreigners had
confidence in President Obama at the end
of his term just 22% and confidence in
Trump favorability toward the United
States dropped from 64% to 49% as well
confidence in President Trump to do the
right thing versus Obama dropped in
every single country except for to
Israel where President Obama was widely
and correctly perceived to be
anti-israel Pro around pro-palestinian
49% of Israelis trusted Obama to do the
right thing vs. 56% for Trump and Russia
where Trump consistently sycophantic
rhetoric toward the Russian government
did not go unnoticed
11% trusted Obama vs. 53% for Trump the
countries that saw the biggest drops are
generally sophisticated democratic
socialist countries like Sweden 83%
dropped the Netherlands 75 percent drop
in Germany 75 percent dropped the
different views of Obama and Trump on
the world stage reflect the basic truth
foreigners prefer a reticent America
first it is unfair to Trump to pretend
that is unpopularity globally is some
sort of Republican outlier by the time
george w bush left office his ratings
were almost identical to Trump's in the
UK France Germany and Spain that's not a
shock the world loves in America that
pays their bills without attempting to
promote any of our interests in fact the
Pew poll also shows that Trump is more
unpopular than Vladimir Putin a
murderous thug dictator who is invaded
foreign countries with regularity
foreigners prefer American policy that
favors our on nuclear weapon development
49% vs. 34% more Muslim immigration 62%
to 32%
support for climate change strictures 71
percent to 19 percent and lack of a
border wall 76 percent to 16 percent
they see Trump as the arrogance 75
percent intolerant 65 percent in
dangerous 62 percent but 55 percent also
see Trump as a strong leader
again not a shock 46 percent of
foreigners just like American ideas
about democracy against just 43 percent
to approve which is weird since we
actually promote a democracy across the
world fifty-four percent complain about
American ideas and customs spreading
here again weird since they watch all of
our movies and consume all of our
product and herein lies the truth about
Trump all of the foibles to which
commentator
are apt to attribute his unpopularity
with foreigners our mere cover for the
real issue that Trump is not a left
winger who wants to minimize American
power on the world stage while turning
over our moral leadership to the UN all
of which suggests that Trump is right
America first policymaking which is a
radical shift away from the
multipolarity sought by the Obama
administration is what is truly annoying
people around the globe which is good if
the alternative is the moral cowardice
of the Obama administration for the last
eight years i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show so dude CNN is having a
rough week and we're going to get into
it plus we're going to breakdown Trump
care we're going to talk about what
exactly the the Congressional Budget
Office had to say about it yesterday
plus we're going to deconstruct the
culture so jam-packed show coming up for
you before I do that I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at bull and
branch so as I frequently say on the
program I am not good at sleeping I'm
good at many things sleeping is not one
of them I tend to sleep lightly I don't
tend to sleep well and that's why I
really need great sheets and that is
where bull and branch comes in bol el
and branch so bull and branch is the
best sheets I've ever slept on bar none
I've gone out and bought several sheets
for myself you know just because they're
so good I can't sleep on other sheets
now we literally threw out our other
sheets because bull and branch are so
comfortable bull and branch sheets are
super comfortable they breathe like you
don't know what it's like to sleep on a
really nice sheet until you do and bull
and branch does that they sell
exclusively on lines you're not paying
expensive retail markup half the price
twice the quality they're crafted from
100% organic cotton they also look
terrific this is why they have thousands
of five-star reviews if you go to Boleyn
branch calm today you get $50 off your
first set of sheets plus free shipping
when you use that promo code Ben so you
go to bull and branch Bo ll and branch
calm use the promo code Ben again that's
bull and branch calm promo code Ben it's
not just their softest sheets they are
breathable they keep you cool at night
but warm enough I mean they're just
they're fancy I can't speak highly
enough of these sheets they're really
fantastic
bull and branch calm today $50 off your
first set of sheets plus free shipping
when you use the promo code Ben Plus use
that promo code events that they know
that we sent you as they are advertisers
on the program okay so we begin with
what is hilarious video
o'keefe who is constantly ripped by the
news media because they don't like that
he goes undercover to do his journalism
he was originally responsible for
breaking acorn the the community
organizing organization responsible for
pushing left-wing agenda James O'Keefe
has now dropped a video of CNN senior
producer John Bona field
John bought a field I guess is a senior
health producer or something but he's a
senior producer talking candidly about
CNN's treatment of the Trump
administration generally and Trump
Russia collusion allegations
specifically and it's just spectacular
stuff here's Ramiz O'Keefe's Project
Veritas CNN producer John bono fell
basically acknowledging and agreeing
that all of our preconceptions about
CNN's bias and their agenda are exactly
right so usually like the Russia things
a little crazy right
even if pressure was trying to swing an
election I we try to swing their
election
we're in the are CIA do it all the time
like we're out there trying to
manipulate a couple it's like you win
because you know you know the game and
you play right shouldn't play around the
mind CNN constantly like Russia this
rush for that this is rating goes rating
arrays are incredible right now but on a
feed you think that whole Russia if it's
just like fold could be hoped is most of
it right now
like we don't have any regen proof I
feel like they don't really have it but
they it was a key thing so I think the
president is proud of right today I look
you are which I think like have no
slogan god there's no real proof to the
CEO of CNN and in our internal meeting
he said good job everybody covering the
climate Accord but we're done with that
let's get back to Russia okay so he's
saying a bunch of things here that we
already knew number one CNN is focusing
on Russia for the ratings which is
obvious I mean they focused on Malaysian
flight mh370 like three years and had
Don Lemon talking about black holes
opening up in the sky to eats what you
don't love them doesn't know anything so
it's not a shock that they've been
focusing on Russia and this is true
right if it doesn't matter what's going
on in the news if you turn over to CNN
what you get is Trump Russia and the
reason is because CNN has been providing
wish fulfillment for the far left for
months now the wish fulfillment is that
Trump was going to get caught colluding
with Russia
he'll somehow be ousted as Sally Kohn
says well the special election then
Hillary Clinton will be President okay
that's what CNN has been doing for
literally months this has been their
agenda it has raised their ratings when
there actually is news to break then
CNN's ratings are good when there's no
no news to break and they're just
spouting about Russia still then there's
not like tonight I think CNN is supposed
to be running a special about Trump
Russia the big story and there's nothing
there there's nothing there and bono
Feld is honest enough to admit that
although he probably wouldn't have
admitted it if he knew his own take when
he says that the Jeff Zucker the head of
C
then told all the producers that when
they were covering the Paris climate
Accords and Trump's pullout from them
that you get back to talking Russia
because he wants the ratings again this
is just confirmation what we already
knew
Bono Feld also said that if CNN had
treated Obama like this he wouldn't have
gone over well at all because obviously
their fans tend to like Obama whereas
they hate Trump and so they have been
wildly dishonest and how they have
covered Trump it's all true okay
everything that bono field is saying is
true and all of it confirms what we
already knew about CNN which is that
they are biasing their journalism in
order to target president Trump and he
is right there on a president Trump is
right they are on a witch-hunt now that
wasn't the only bad story for CNN last
night so CNN also fired three
journalists responsible for a single
source anonymous story that they broke
at cnn.com they were accusing Trump
associate Anthony Sierra Moochie of
being investigated by the Senate
Intelligence Committee for contact with
a Russian bank a few days before the
inauguration CNN ended up retracting the
story and firing the three journalists
responsible for the story naturally as
my friend John Nolte points out CNN also
added that it's possible but the facts
of the story weren't necessarily wrong
so this is a DNA approach we're going to
retract the story we're going to fire
the guy responsible but it's possible
that the facts were still correct okay
again just the evidence of CNN's bias so
this of course sets off President Trump
and president from promptly tweets quote
fakes and fake news CNN is looking at
big management changes now that they got
caught falsely pushing their phony
Russian stories rating is way down first
half is true the second half is not the
ratings are not way down the ratings are
actually way up because of all the
conspiratorial bullcrap it would be
better if the ratings were down because
of all the conspiratorial bullcrap but
they aren't innate as well CNN had to
attract big story on Russia with three
employees forced to resign what about
all the other phony stories they do fake
news again totally fair and then he said
you know fake news this fake news that
fake news what about the Washington Post
and there are times and ABC and NBC and
CBS right so all of this there is truth
to this obviously cNN has biases they
refuse to acknowledge their biases it's
one of the more annoying things about
Ciena if they just said listen we're
left-wing outlet like MSNBC like no one
cares that MSNBC covers Russia
incessantly because MSNBC is openly to
the left
I mean they're leaning forward right CNN
pretends is objective which is why CNN
is the easiest whipping boy in the media
business and I will say that CNN did
more than for example the Trump
administration has done when people in
the administration have lied
they actually fired people forthwith
when this story came out they fired
three reporters now does this mean that
they're suddenly great at their jobs no
but that's at least a form of
accountability naturally Fox News jumped
on this as well jumped on all of this
Tucker Carlson ripped CNN to their
propaganda organization again this is
mostly right it's been seven months
though since Trump won the presidential
election since then precisely no
evidence has emerged support the claim
that somehow Kaleta dwith the Russian
government in order to win the race but
you'd never know that from watching that
channel which has become home for
conspiracists on the Russia question
worldwide last February's named yet
another example to improve the story
accusing Trump associates of repeated
contacts with Russian intelligence that
report turned out to be almost identical
to a report by the New York Times that
Jim Comey called out specifically for
being grossly inaccurate we could go on
and on and on overall 93% of CNN's
coverage of the Trump administration has
been negative everything tells anything
here in here that CNN is an anti-trump
machine no question about it and then
Sean Hannity goes on TV last night and
he called for Jeff Zucker the head of
CNN to be fired he says hey CNN when
will you fire Zucker he has destroyed
the network with lies and very fake news
very fake news now again I think that
Sean calling for Zucker to be fired over
the coverage CNN is a mistake for Sean I
mean I defended Sean over the Seth rich
stuff not because I thought he was right
on it but because I don't like these
kind of astroturf spoi cots where people
ends up losing their job because they
don't like the way that somebody is
covering the news and here's Sean
calling for Jeff Zucker to be fired over
his coverage of the news again I just
did the hypocrisy is a little much for
me but is all this criticism of CNN fair
absolutely it's fair but I do want to
discuss whether the term fake news is
useful or not anymore because I'm not
sure that it is useful so when fake news
was originally coined the term fake news
is originally coined what it meant was a
story that was outright false so for
example that piece that CNN retracted
that was actual
make news right that was a piece of fake
news CNN's Russia collusion stuff when
they actually tried to avert that there
is collusion or evidence there up that
is fake news it is not fake news when
they report a specific story about a
trump associate who had a contact with
russians and then it's verified right
it's not a fake story when CNN reports
about what Trump said to sort of get kis
lyac in the Oval Office right that is
not fake news so we have to distinguish
two types of news that people don't like
one type of news is news that it's just
the facts are wrong right that's actual
fake news we don't like those those
those are real fake news and then there
are stories where we don't like the
angle the news is taking we don't like
the bias that's being infused into the
news and this is where I find trouble
because you know President Trump is out
there saying all these networks are
quote unquote fake news fake news if you
conflate these two categories you make
it so that it is impossible to have a
common basis of fact for any sort of
political conversations when he says CNN
is fake news I don't think that's right
I don't I think that CNN is a wildly
wefts news outlet that biases their
coverage in tremendous ways I don't
think that's quote-unquote fake news you
say fake objective news right that's
true it's non objective news that's true
when you just say it's fake news like
everything you see on see on CNN is
false that's not true and this is coming
from a guy who went on CNN in 2014 and
said if Hamas could design a propaganda
network it would look a lot like CNN is
in the middle of the Gaza war so it's
not like I have any great love and honor
for CNN I mean for God's sake I
basically destroyed one of their main
hosts on their on their show right I'm
done I took Piers Morgan and destroyed
him on CNN Nev rip CNN on CNN multiple
times so this is not about defending CNN
this is about as the American public how
do we know what information we can trust
and what information we can't we sort of
have the busy me problem you remember
from Princess Bride where Vizzini gets
into a battle of wits with Wesley and
the seamy has the the Wesley takes AI
Akane powder and supposedly he puts it
in one of the two cups and then Vizzini
who's the coopera Stran alive according
to Vizzini has to try and outwit him
does he doesn't I'm out a great fool so
I can clearly not choose the wine in
front of you but you must have known I
was not a great fool so you would and
you would have counted on it so I can
clearly not choose the wine in front of
me right remember that whole routine
what happened when President Trump
routinely says things that are not true
or Sean Hannity says things about
rich that are unverified I mean last
night Sean Hannity was still on Twitter
going on as saying he's still
investigating the Seth rich thing which
is you know come on I mean really like
enough already like you have no new
evidence you talk about Trump collusion
Trump Russia collusion has no evidence
you have no evidence on the on the South
rich stuff but you're still pursuing it
and then claiming conspiracy theories on
the other side this is just about a
little bit of intellectual honesty folks
if you can't trust Trump and you can't
trust Fox and you can't trust CNN then
who can you trust
and I'm not suggesting that you can
trust me by the way to be unbiased
because I'm pretty open about my biases
I'm conservative right I'm conservative
that means that my coverage of the news
is going to be infused with a certain
level of conservative bias for sure but
it is a mistake to label every single
mainstream media outlet fake news as
president Trump does because it actually
blows back on Trump the next time CNN
reports something that is true and Trump
calls it fake news Trump looks like a
liar he's right he is right that all of
these outlets are biased against him he
is right that they attacked him in a way
they never would have attacked President
Obama and I'm glad that President Trump
goes up against the media all the time
in my book bullies I said this is
exactly what politicians should do but
the point in bullies was that you should
you should go after these outlets when
they lie you shouldn't just label the
entire outlet completely uncredible and
and suggest that everything that they
report is false because that's not
actually true like if you're going to
defeat lies you have to do it with truth
you can't and if you're going to defeat
bias you have to do it by calling out
the bias you can't defeat bias by just
saying that everything that somebody
says that is biased is complete fake
news and all lies and garbage right
right now what we have is Trump attacks
combined with the media's ruling
preoccupation with getting Trump it ends
up polarizing the narrative right now
I'm telling because that is the world I
live in right now people on the right
will not believe a word that comes from
CNN or the New York Times or The
Washington Post even though all of their
favorite websites you know Breitbart I
used to work there right out of the
editor-at-large for four years I was
deeply involved in editorial for two of
those four years
Breitbart which is a very pro term
website obviously they ripped half their
news from the mainstream media at least
okay the notion that Breitbart is doing
original reporting is not true I mean
they do some original reporting but the
bulk of what they cover is a Breitbart
angle on a news story that has been
previously reported by CNN or the New
York Times the same thing is true in
talk radio and everybody in talk radio
will acknowledge this right I mean the
fact is that when you listen to Rush
listen to Sean Catherine strands
coverage on his radio show is him
reading an AP story and then
deconstructing the AP story trying to
get to the fact so pretending that all
of the news is fake is just not true and
what you end up with is this bizarre
situation where people on the right will
only trust Fox News and people on the
Left will only trust CNN and if they
hear that something happened on Fox News
they go it's complete crap
if Benghazi is perfect example Fox News
was leading the charge in terms of
uncovering material about Benghazi and
the Lefter said oh it's Fox News who
cares and then the right does the same
thing with CNN every time there's a
story bad for Trump that CNN who cares I
want to talk about what we should do to
defeat all this how you can watch the
news and get more out of it but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at the u.s. concealed-carry
Association so if you are somebody who
wants to buy a gun or has it gone and
lacks training or you're afraid that you
may become involved in a situation where
god forbid somebody breaks in your house
you have to shoot them in self-defense
and then the police arrest you that's
what u.s. CCA is for they educate you
they train you they make sure that you
are legally and financially protected
for after you pull the trigger because
doesn't matter whether you're right or
wrong it's very possible you ends up in
legal system anyway and one of the
things that are doing right now that is
super cool is they're making sure that
if you don't have a way to defend
yourself or if you just want a better
way to defend yourself you have five
opportunities right now to win one
thousand seven hundred seventy six
dollars for guns and ammo of your choice
in honor of July 4th right 1776 they are
going to give you 1776 dollars for the
guns and ammo of your choice if you go
and you you have a chance to win that if
you go and register at defend my family
now.com defend my family now I come to
get five big chances to win 1776 dollars
for any guns and ammo of your choice
again that's defend my family now calm
for your free shot at that money yeah so
hurry it's not going to last long
obviously July 4th is just around the
corner defend my family now.com right
now you get your big five chances to win
1776 dollars for the guns and ammo of
your choice you should register there
anyway because everything again they
have all of these resources for gun
training and protection against against
legal liability and all the rest of it
it's just it's a great organization
they're doing the stuff that gun owners
need and they're making sure that more
people are there making sure that more
people know how to protect themselves
and are capable of doing so legally
when the time if God forbid the time
comes you actually have to use the
weapon against somebody that's the u.s.
CCN go to defend my family now calm okay
so here's how I want to boil down all of
this media debate and again CNN is what
they are they're wildly biased anti
right network masquerading is an
objective news source sometimes running
stories without proper substantiation
that they then have to back off them but
to pretend that every piece of CNN
coverage is a lie is not true just as
for the left to pretend during the Obama
years that everything coming out of Fox
News was not true here are some basic
truths they're only three of them so you
can handle this we're all capable of
handling this okay all journalists are
biased all of them even if they won't
admit it there's some who try harder to
keep their own biases out of the news
and I think that there there are people
who are widely hated on the right and
widely hated on the left banding Bret
Baier does a good job of trying to keep
his biases out of the news I think on
the left then Jake Tapper's clearly the
left I think Tapper does a better job
than most of trying to keep his biases
out of the news although Jake obviously
has some biases but all journalists are
biased okay anyone who pretends not is
lying to you second either the facts of
a story are factual or they are not okay
there's two parts to every story there's
the fact and there's the opinion and you
have to become kind of sophisticated in
how you look at the news this is why you
listen to or watch shows like this so we
can break down a story and explain to
you what is opinion from what is fact
what is actually being said in the news
story and what is the the news media
getting out ahead of themselves right
the facts of a story are either factual
however or they are not the bias of a
journalist may impact how the facts are
presented but it doesn't automatically
discredit the facts that are presented
so if CNN covers the Trump Russia stuff
and then draws a conclusion there's
collusion and the conclusion is wrong
that doesn't discredit the underlying
facts upon which they are reporting
maybe their conclusion is wrong because
they're biased maybe the way that a
reporting the story is wrong because
they're biased but that doesn't
necessarily mean that the underlying
facts are wrong the same is true on the
right right the left would suggest that
the rights coverage of the IRS scandal
was all lies is all fake news but that
did not discredit any of the underlying
factual claims that Lois Lerner and the
IRS were obviously targeting
conservative 501 C 3 s in an attempt to
provide
them from being able to raise money and
that they were doing so because
Democrats have been calling for years
for them to do exactly that right that
was the underlying news now the left may
not have liked the conclusion the right
was run which is that Obama basically
ordered it but that didn't discredit the
underlying news so it is your job as a
news consumer to try and distinguish the
fact from the opinion in any given story
without just doing this routine where
you say okay see and then is all fake
news or fox news is all fake news and
everybody should be fired because I
disagree with them again do I think CNN
is egregious yes I think they're
egregious in their coverage of Trump I
think they're just egregious in their
coverage of Trump and I think that
producer demonstrates how egregious they
are in their coverage of Trump but that
does not actually change the underlying
facts and to pretend that CNN doesn't
feel the heat when they do something
wrong is just so lame and they just
fired three reporters we make a living
over at Daily wire bashing CNN when they
get things wrong right instances to
pretend that they are not subject to
scrutiny is just dishonest so again this
is not a defense of CNN's activity
anywhere along the line here but I'm
suggesting to you that you're going to
be blindsided by the news if you do what
so many on the writers doing and say I
only trust the people on the right to
report me the news even though the
people on the right are relying on the
left to actually report those facts okay
CNN has staff on the ground daily wire
is not independently reporting from
Yemen and the truth is neither is Fox
News in many cases so if you want to
clarify all of that because I think
it'll make you a better news consumer
and better able to distinguish between
good and news coverage and bad news
coverage instead of doing this
ridiculous partisan knee-jerk crap or
people at CNN go people in left go Oh
Fox News can't be trusted everything
they say is a lie and people fo News
right they did this for eight years I
was there and people on the right going
oh it's from the New York Times how dare
you quote the New York Times I promise
you Gateway pundit is quoting that same
New York Times story whether it's an
attempt to debunk the New York Times
story or an attempt to grant credibility
to the New York Times story because most
reporting is done by the mainstream
media outlets to dedicate hundreds of
millions of dollars every year to
sending reporters to the field okay I
want to talk about the breakdown in
Trump care and where that goes from here
but for that you're going to have to
subscribe so for $8 a month you too can
subscribe to daily wire comm you get the
rest of the show live you also can
listen to you can also become part of
the mailbag we do that on Fridays
get all of your deepest most and most
fascinating questions answered on the
mailbag you also get to be part of
Clavin show and you get to check into
Cravens mailbag as well we have some new
shows coming which will be quite
exciting as well if you want an annual
subscription $8 a month annual
subscription then you can do that you
get a free signed copy of this book say
it's so booked by me and my dad all
about baseball and fathers and sons
really fun enjoyable book terrific
bathroom book say it so Papa Dabney in
the 2005 White Sox championship season I
will sign it for you as well so you can
go over to Daley wire.com check it out
right now by the way if you're trying to
subscribe either just monthly or if you
want to get the annual subscription do
it now lock in your rate because by July
10th we are switching the race everybody
who is already subscribed it's not
changing for you but if you are trying
to lock in a lower right now now is the
time to do it so go and buy the
subscription now if you're thinking
about it and we think you're going to do
it in a month do it now get that lower
rate eight dollars a month daily
wired.com go and check it out if you
want to listen to us later check us out
iTunes SoundCloud Google Play make sure
that you subscribe and leave us a review
we always appreciate it we are the
largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
you